while the cgi dinosaurs in the hit film
jurassic world dominion continue to
frighten moviegoers in theaters around
the country
a real dinosaur has been on display at
the sotheby's auction house here in new
york
it's a gorgosaurus a close relative of
the much bigger and better known t-rex
and it's expected to go for a jurassic
sized price between five and eight
million dollars if not more when the
bidding ends later this month tom holtz
is a professor of paleontology at the
university of maryland and the
smithsonian so gorgosaurus is a
tyrannosaur that means it's a cousin of
t-rex and if you picture t-rex it's kind
of the suv version it's big it's bulky
it's powerful gorgosaurus would be the
sports car model it's smaller it's sleek
it's faster gorgosaurus is the kind of
animal you wouldn't want to meet in a
dark alley or a brightly lit street or
pretty much anywhere
[Music]
the 22 foot long 10 foot high skeleton
was discovered in north central montana
in 2018.
the location near the judith river
formation has been giving up dinosaur
fossils for over a century but this was
a particularly spectacular find
complete or relatively complete dinosaur
skeletons are still pretty rare now
there have been some fairly complete
gorgosaurus that have been found in the
past but anytime we find one that is an
important new discovery because it gives
us more information about their anatomy
the gorgosaurus roamed what is now the
western u.s and canada during the late
cretaceous period around 70 million
years ago while it does resemble a t-rex
its behavior may have been different
because of the size of its prey many
paleontologists speculate the
gorgosaurus must have hunted in packs we
find multiple individuals of them
found together in death which is makes
us think that they may have lived
together in life or footprint sites
where we see multiple individuals that
were walking together at the same time
back in 1997 sotheby's sold the first
ever dinosaur at auction an enormous
t-rex skeleton nicknamed sue for 8.3
million dollars only time will tell if
this gorgosaurus will be able to take
down the mighty t-rex on the auction
block
and it is interesting i'm sure somebody
with a lot of money who would like to
have it in their large home might get
this but paleontologists some of them
out there are concerned because they
think you have this specimen that's in
such good shape that they could learn
from so maybe somebody with a lot of
money will donate it to a museum to a
museum or somewhere so that you get the
best of both worlds it was this is legal
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
some of the scientists out there but
when it's so rare and there's so much to
learn for history and science sake it
would be nice to have it in a museum
best of both worlds